>
, FLORIDA IS
AVE MOREACUATION AR
WHAT'S THE STATUS, BILL?
PEOPLE ARE VERY MUCH OGE.
EYA LITTMER THAN
THE ON EASTER SUNDAY
WORRIED THAT THIBASICA
MA CASTLE OF
BACK THIS HUGE
POND, RELY SMALL LAK
THIS POLLUR COULD GIVE
WAY.
DY.
BEYOND PAE WORST CASEO IS THA2
AB0 HOMES OR SARE
THE FOLKTHE BEEN
EVACUATED.
BUT THIS IS A TI BOM
YOU GOT TO UNDERSTAND THIS STATE
N IT
COMES TO MAKING PHOSPHOROUFERTIK
THIS STUFF AND DIG IT UP
CREATES F THIS
LIGHTLY RADIOACTIVE TOXIC ST
SO THEY DON'T KNOW WHATOO
THE EPA HAS NEVED OUT A
WAY TO GET RIDIT.
THEY PILEDSETACKS,
THEY'RE THESE 500-FOOTOU
AT THE TOPE ARE THESE
TOS
AC ENV
HAVE BEEN WARNING FOR YEARS.
PHOSOUE ORA R WHERY  UNDER THE
IN THE STATE GETS THEIR DRINKING
IF
BREAKS.
THGHT LY WAY IS TO GF
GALLONS, TENSE OF NG IT INTOY IR
MILLIO ARE BEING PPE
THAT WATER IS FULL OF SORTIENT H
BASICALLY STEROTHE RED UE
FLORIDA IN RECENT YEARS THAT
KILL MILON FISH ANER
THE BEACHES WITH FISH GILS RIGHT
NOW.
SO IT'S A EDU DO TUATION, DAMMET